This class today is about language
and language is to a large extent,
um,
where the action is.
The study of human language has been the
battleground over different theories of
human nature.
So every philosopher or a psychologist
or humanist or neuroscientists who has
ever thought about people has had to
make some claim about the nature of
language and how it works.
I'm including here people
like Aristotle and Plato,
Hume,
lock,
Freud and Skinner.
I'm also including modern day
approaches to computational theory,
cognitive neuroscience,
evolutionary theory and
cultural psychology.
Um,
if you hope to make it with a theory
of what people are and how people work,
you have to explain and
talk about language.
Um,
in fact,
language is sufficiently interesting
that unlike most other things I'll talk
about in this class,
there is an entire field devoted to it.
Study the field of linguistics that is
entirely devoted to studying the nuances
and structures of different languages.
Now,
our first,
before getting the details
make a definitional point.
When I'm talking about language,
I meaning a systems like English and
Dutch and wall Perri and Italian and
Turkish and Urdu.
And what we've seen and heard right
now in class and a demonstration that
proceeded,
uh,
the formal lecture.
Um,
now you could use language
in a different sense.
You could use no term language to describe
what dogs do or with chimpanzees do
our birds.
You could use language to describe music,
talk about immune musical language
or art or any communicative system.
And there's absolutely
nothing wrong with that.
There's no rule about how you're
supposed to use the word language.
But the problem is if you use the word
language impossibly incredibly broadly,
then from a scientific point of view,
it becomes useless to ask
interesting questions about it.
If language can again refer to just
about everything from English to traffic
signals,
then we're not going to be able to find
interesting generalizations or do good
science about it.
So what I want to do is I want to discuss
a scientific notion of language at
first restricting myself to systems
like English and Dutch and American sign
language and Navajo and so on.
Once we've made some generalizations
about language in this narrow sense,
we could then ask and we will ask to what
extent do other systems such as animal
communication systems,
um,
relate to this narrower definition.
So we could ask him this narrow sense,
what properties do languages have and
then go on to ask in a broader sense what
other communicative systems
also possess those properties.
Well,
some things are obvious about language.
Um,
so,
um,
here's,
here are the questions we will ask.
This will frame our discussion today.
We'll first go over some
basic facts about language.
We'll talk about what language is share,
we'll talk about how language develops
and we'll talk about language and
communication in nonhumans.
I began this class who have a,
a demonstration of that that illustrates
two very important facts about
language.
One is that language is all share
some deep and intricate universals in
particular.
All languages at minimum are powerful
enough to convey an abstract notion like
this abstract in the sense that it talks
about thoughts and it talks about our
proposition and and,
and,
and spatial relations and objects.
There is no language in the world that
you just cannot talk about abstract
things with every language can do this.
But the demonstration also illustrated
another fact about language,
which is how different languages are.
They sound different.
If you know one language,
you don't necessarily know another.
It's not merely that
you can't understand it.
It could sound strange or or or look
unusual in the case of a sign language.
And so there any adequate theory of
language has to allow for both the
commonalities and the
differences across languages.
And this is the puzzle faced by the
psychology and cognitive science of
language.
Well,
let's start with an interesting claim
about language made by Charles Darwin.
So Darwin rights man has an instinctive
tendency to speak as we see in the
babble of our young children.
While no child has an
instinctive tendency to bake,
brew or right.
And what Darwin is claiming here,
and it's a controversial
and interesting claim,
is that language is special
in that there's some sort
of propensity or capacity
or instinct for language.
Unlike the other examples,
he gifts,
not everything comes natural to us,
but Darwin suggests
that language does well.
Why should we believe this?
Well,
there are some basic facts
that support Darwin's claim.
Um,
for one thing,
every normal,
every human society has language
in the course of traveling.
Cultures encounter other cultures and
they often encounter cultures that are
very different from their own.
But through the course of human history,
nobody has ever encountered another group
of humans that did not have language.
Does this show that is built in?
Well,
not necessarily.
It could be a cultural innovation.
It could be,
for instance,
that language is such a good idea that
every culture comes across and develops
it.
Just about every culture uses some sort
of utensils to eat food with a knife and
a fork,
chopsticks a spoon.
Um,
this probably is not because use of,
of eating utensils,
it's human nature,
but rather it's because it's just a very
useful thing that culture is discover
over and over again.
Well,
we know that this probably is
not true with regard to language.
And one reason we know
this is because of the,
the demonstrated,
um,
case studies where a language is
created within a single generation.
And these case studies
have happened over history.
The client that the standard example is,
um,
people involved in the slave trade.
The slave trade revolving around tobacco
or cotton or coffee or sugar would tend
to mix slaves and labors from
different language backgrounds in part
deliberately so as to avoid
the possibility of revolt.
Um,
what would happen is these people who
were in slave from different cultures
would develop a makeshift communication
system so they could talk to one
another.
And this is called a pigeon,
Piv Gin,
a pigeon.
Um,
and this pigeon was how they were talk
and this pigeon was not a language,
it was strings of words borrowed from
the different languages around them and
put together and sort of haphazard ways.
The question is what happens to the
children who are raised in this society?
And you might expect it that they
would come to speak a pigeon,
but they don't.
What happens is in the course
of a single generation,
they develop their own language.
They create a language with rich syntax
and morphology and more and phonology
terms that will understand
in a few minutes.
Um,
and this language that they create is
called a cradle and languages that we know
now as creoles.
Um,
the word refers back to their history.
That means that they were
developed from pigeons.
Um,
and this is interesting cause this
suggest that to some extent the ability to
use and understand and learn
languages part of human nature.
It doesn't require an extensive cultural
history rather just about any normal
child even when not exposed to a full
fledge language can create a language.
And more recently there's been case
studies of children who acquire sign
language.
Um,
there was a wonderful case
of Nicaraguan sign language,
um,
where they acquire sign language from
adults who themselves are not versed in
sign language.
They're sort of second language learners
struggling along what you might've
expected would be the children would
then use whatever system they're adults
use,
but they don't,
they creole lies it.
They take this makeshift communication
system developed by adults and again,
they turn it into a full blown language
suggesting that to some extent it's part
of our human nature to create languages.
Um,
also every normal human has language.
Not everybody in this
room can ride a bicycle.
Not Everybody in this room can play chess,
but everybody possesses at least one
language and everybody started to possess
at least one language.
Um,
when they were a child.
There are exceptions,
but the exceptions come about
due to some sort of brain damage.
Any neurologically normal human
will come to possess a language.
What else do we know?
Well,
the claim that language is part of human
nature is supported by neurological
studies,
some which were referred to in the
chapter on the brain that you read earlier
that talk about dedicated
parts of the brain,
um,
that work for language.
And if parts of these brains as parts,
if these parts of the brain are damaged,
you get language deficits or or aphasias
where you might lose the ability to
understand or create language.
Um,
more speculatively.
There has been some fairly recent work
studying the genetic basis of language,
looking at the genes that are directly
responsible for the capacity to learn and
use language.
And one bit of evidence that these genes
are implicated is that some unfortunate
people have point mutations in these
genes and such people are unable to learn
and use language.
So in general there was some support
at least at a very broad level for the
claim.
That language is in some
sense part of human nature.
Well,
what do we mean by language?
What are we talking about
when we talk about language?
We don't want to restrict ourselves.
For instance,
the English or French.
What do all languages share?
Well,
all languages are creative
and this means a couple of things.
One meaning is the meaning,
um,
emphasized by Rene Descartes when Rene
Descartes argued that we are more than
merely machines.
His best piece of evidence for him
was the human capacity for language.
No machine could do this because our
capacity for language is unbounded and
free.
We could say anything we choose to say
we have free will and in fact language
allows us to produce a
virtual infinity of sentences.
Um,
so we could create an understand sentences
we never heard before and there are a
lot of sentences.
So if you want to estimate how many
grammatical sentences under 20 words in
English to answer is a lot.
Um,
and what this means is that any
theory of language use and language
comprehension cannot
simply appeal to a list.
Yeah.
When you understand the sentence,
I said you have to have the capacity to
understand the sentence even if you've
never heard it before.
And this is because we get effortlessly
produced and understand sentences that
no human has ever said before on earth.
Okay.
Would anybody volunteer to
say a sentence non obscene,
non derogatory but has never
been spoken before on earth ever.
Okay.
Here I'll,
I'll start.
Um,
it's surprisingly easy to get a purple
tie on Ebay if you don't care much about
quality.
I could imagine no one else in the world.
He said this before.
Um,
I am upset that one cannot easily
download Buffy the vampire slayer through
iTunes.
Now.
Now there's possible somebody
said both those sentences before.
Um,
but you probably have not heard them,
but you understand them immediately.
So how do you do it?
Well,
okay,
you have rules,
you have rules in your head.
You've learnt what the words mean,
but you have abstract and unconscious
rules that take these words,
figure out the order and in a fraction
of a second give rise to understanding.
And that's the sort of
thing linguists study.
So take some standard examples
from the linguistic study of um,
of English.
And bear in mind,
the rules we're talking
about here are not rules.
You explicitly know.
They're automatic rules of the same
sort we're going to talk about in the
context of visual perception in that
they're implicit and unconscious and not
accessible to,
to explicit understanding.
Um,
so for instance,
um,
immediately you read
the pig is eager to eat
versus the pig is easy to eat
and then a fraction of a second,
you know,
there's an important difference.
The pig is eager to eat means,
uh,
the state of affairs that we're talking
about is when to pig does the eating the
pig is easy to eat is when
the pig is being eaten.
You see a sentence like,
Bill knew that John liked him.
And you know,
without even knowing how,
you know,
did this can mean that bill
knew that John Liked bill?
Or it could mean that
bill knew that John Liked,
uh,
Fred.
But it can't mean that bill
knew that John Liked John.
The natural interpretation factors
that bill knew that John like bill,
the two words co refer.
Contrast that with bill knew
that John Liked himself,
which only has to meaning.
Bill knew that John like John,
and this is what
linguists do for a living.
So if you hear me talking
with them and say,
I want to spend the next 40 years of my
life studying that you should become a
linguist.
Um,
but that's the sort of,
those are the sort of phenomenon
that we're interested in.
Now it gets more complicated.
Those are examples from syntax,
but language has many structures.
Language has structures going
from the bottom to the top,
all languages,
all human languages have phonology,
which is the system of
sounds or science morphology,
which is a system of words or morphemes
basic units of meaning and syntax which
refer to rules and principles that
put together words and phrases into
meaningful utterances.
And I want to talk briefly about each
of these three parts of language before
looking at some other issues.
Um,
I'm indebted here to Steven
Pinker's excellent book,
the language instinct,
which provides I think a superb
discussion of these phenomena.
And I'm going to steal some
of my examples from pinker.
So phonology,
phonology is the system of
sounds that languages have.
Um,
okay.
There's a subset,
there's a list of finite list of
possible sounds that language can use.
I'm going to put aside for the moment
the question of sign languages and how
they work.
We'll talk about them in a little bit.
Um,
the idea is that English has
about 40 of these phonemes.
So if you're a native
monolingual speaker of English,
you hear speech and each sound you hear
is categorized as falling into one of
those 40,
um,
morphemes sorry,
phonemes.
Um,
so for example,
English has a phoneme of
Maror l and a phoneme of our,
and so an English speaker can hear the
difference between lip and rip and that
corresponds to two
different words in English.
Other languages don't
have that distinction.
And so those,
those distinctions are very difficult
for non native English speakers to learn.
So part of what goes on when you learn
is you have to learn the language,
um,
the phonemes that your language has.
Um,
another part of the problem
of learning languages,
you have to figure out what the
boundaries are between the words.
You have to use sound signals to figure
out the boundaries between the words.
Now that if the only language
you've ever heard his English,
that's going to seem like a really weird
example of a problem because you're
listening to me speak.
And in between each of my words,
you're hearing a pause.
Don't have to be very smart to figure
out where one word begins and one word
ends.
But the pause is a psychological illusion.
If you were to talk into an
oscilloscope that measured your sound,
there are no pauses between the words.
Rather the pauses are
inserted by your mind,
um,
as you already know where one
word begins and another one ends,
and you insert a pause at that point,
um,
you could see this.
When you hear a language
you don't already know.
So for those of you who have
never heard French before,
when you hear somebody say [inaudible],
you could say remarkable French
has no pauses between words.
Um,
and you,
and now a French speaker of course,
hears Juna set par for Hebrew.
I know one sentence in Hebrew,
[inaudible] copy,
AFO,
habitual Mousse,
which I think is a
request for the bathroom.
Um,
but if you don't know Hebrew,
there's no pauses.
And the truth is when you
each gave your demonstrations,
nobody spoke properly
because nobody spoke at,
Oh,
here's the,
here's the sand glory,
fennel,
smug wiggle.
Rather,
you all sounded like Boobie,
Boobie,
boobie without any pauses.
Because I don't know your languages.
Children come into the world without
knowing any specific language.
And so they have to learn,
um,
pauses.
They have to learn to
interpret sounds in context.
Um,
and sometimes they make mistakes,
they get problems of segmentation.
And there's some illustrations you could
see the mistakes after trying to repeat
back something that's already
known within a society.
So songs are a good example.
These are excerpts from children.
Um,
I'll never be your pizza Vernon.
Anybody know,
pick her up with that corresponds to
beast of burden.
Very good.
A girl have collitus goes by
somebody.
The answer,
my friends that are blowing in the wind
and,
and this is a religious one.
Our father was Barton Heaven.
Harold be thy name lead
us not into Penn station.
Yeah.
Now phonological understanding illustrates
all sorts of aspects of language
processing and in fact of consciousness.
Because remember I said
that typically when you,
um,
when you hear a sentence you make,
do you manufacturer in your
mind gaps between the words?
Um,
typically when there's
something which is unclear,
you'll fill in the gap and
figure out what the word is.
And you'll hear it that way.
So there's a few examples.
The best examples again
are for when it goes wrong.
So classic example is from the
Song Super Freak by Rick James.
I got a big lecture of
a copyright laws and,
and this is going to violate most of them.
Um,
Rick James is going to be sitting on no
at steering at the web two years from
now saying,
Hey,
that's my thing.
Okay.
So I want you to listen to this line.
I'm sure.
I'm sure most of you
have heard this before.
Um,
but I want you to listen closely.
What was that last line?
The kind of girl you read about?
Well,
it turns out that nobody really knows.
Um,
and it sounds to many people who do top
down interpretation as to meet as well,
that she used to kind of go,
you read about in Newsweek magazine,
but that makes no sense at all given that
you don't want to bring home to mamma
and she's just not the end.
In fact,
if you check the notes on a song,
she's in fact the kind of girl you
read about in new wave magazines.
Now when you listen to it,
then again knowing that
you hear it that way.
Now this top down,
this is known as top down processing,
top down processing is an example of um,
when you know what something is,
you hear it that way.
And this is extremely useful
when it comes to filling in gaps,
um,
in,
in the sounds,
in normal conversation.
If I'm just to say,
I said endurance.
Yeah,
you won't hear that as it cough.
Rather you hear a sentence,
you fill in the gap.
Um,
this can lead to problems.
The problem is led to in my life
revolves around the song get crunk.
Um,
because because,
um,
I heard get crunk and,
and um,
my children asked me if I would buy them,
get crunk from iTunes.
My children are eight and
10 and now now get crunk.
As I was aware from
having heard it before,
involves a consistent refrain
of get crunk extremely bad word,
get crunk extremely bad word.
And so I said No.
And then they said,
well,
there's a clean version of,
so I downloaded the clean version.
Um,
unfortunately,
knowing what the clean version,
knowing what the word is means to me.
The clean version is not very clean.
Now I will add,
I will add
before people write letters and stuff.
This is the clean version.
Thank,
thank goodness they took
away that I've seen work.
Okay.
So top down processing affects how we
hear things usually almost always the
better.
And in fact,
this is a theme we're going to return
to next class when we talk about vision
because the same thing's
going to happen there.
Um,
how we see the world is often
confusing and be fuddle.
But what we know can clear things up.
Same with sound.
Morphology is the next level up.
Phonology is sounds morphology as words
and human language uses this amazing
trick,
um,
described by Ferdinand de.
So sir,
the great linguist as the
arbitrariness of the sign.
And what this means is we can use,
take any arbitrary idea in the world,
the idea of a chair or a story or a
country and make a sound or assigned to
connect to it.
And the link is arbitrary.
I mean you might choose to use the word
for dog as wolf wolf cause it sounds
like a dog,
but you can't use a word for
country that sounds like a country.
You could use a sign
language thing for um,
for drink that looks sort
of like the act of drinking,
but you can't use a sign language word
for country that looks like a country or
for idea that looks like an idea.
So way language has work is it
allows for arbitrary naming.
It allows for this map between a symbol,
say a spoken word and uh,
any sort of thought we want to use.
And those arbitrary mappings as we come
to learn them make up the vocabulary of
a language.
MMM.
I'm talking about words,
but the more technical term is morphine.
And what a morpheme is,
is the smallest meaningful
unit in a language.
Now often this is the
same thing as a word.
So dog is a word and
dog is also a morphine,
but not always because
there a single morphemes.
And then there are words that
are composed of many more themes.
So dogs and complained our one word,
but to morphemes.
And what this means is that you make the
word by putting together two morphemes
to put it differently.
In order to know what dogs means,
you never had to learn the word dogs.
All you had to know is the word dog and
the plural morpheme s and you could put
them together to create a word.
How many morphemes does
the average speaker?
Now,
um,
the answer is fairly startling.
The average speaker knows as a low
ball estimate about 60,000 words.
I think the proper estimate is
closer to 80,000 or 100,000.
What this means,
if you average it out,
is that since children start learning
their first words that about their first
year of life,
um,
they about nine new words a day.
And it's not a continuous,
uh,
nine words every day.
It goes up and down depending on the age.
But still the amount of
words we know is staggering.
How many of you know more than
one language pretty fluidly?
Okay?
Those of you who know other languages
might have in your heads 200,000 words or
300,000 words,
and you're accessing them
in a fraction of a second,
it,
it is legitimate,
could legitimately be seen as
one of the most astonishing,
um,
things that people do.
Finally,
Syntax.
So we have the sound system of language,
the phonology,
we have the words of a language,
their morphology,
but all of that gives
you his dog cup chair,
House story,
idea that won't allow us to
communicate complicated ideas.
So the final step in the story is syntax.
And Syntax refers to those rules and
principles that allow us to combine words
into phrases and phrases and descendants
and syntax uses another neat trick.
And this is defined by Belheim von Humbolt
as the infinite use of finite media.
So here's the question.
Your vocabulary is finite.
There are just so many words.
You have to learn them one by one,
okay?
But you could produce a
virtual infinity of sentences.
How can you do that?
How can you go from a
finite list of symbols to an
infinite number of sentences?
And the answer is you have
a common editorial system.
Now,
language is not the only thing in
culture or nature that has a sort of
combination tutorial system.
Um,
music also has a common tutorial system.
There's a finite number of notes,
but a limitless number
of musical compositions.
DNA also has this sort of common tutorial
system where you have a finite number
of,
I guess bases are amino acids that
could combine to a possible infinity of
strings,
uh,
of,
of DNA strings.
So how does this happen?
Well,
infinity mechanism,
and many of you will be familiar with
this from mathematics or computer science
is recursion.
And there's a lot to be said about this,
but it can be pretty simply
illustrated in language.
So here's an example of a simple language.
It's not,
it's actually close to how linguist
described normal languages,
but it's very simple.
It has three nouns.
Fred Barney and woman and two verbs
thinks and likes the very simple language.
And one rule.
And the way to this rule is you
make a sentence by taking a noun,
any noun,
putting a verb after it.
And then following that verb with a noun.
Now when you do this,
how many?
And then,
so for instance,
you get the sentence,
Fred likes Wilma.
When you do this,
how many possible sentences are there?
Can we just take a second?
Okay.
Any guesses?
Yeah.
18.
Um,
the sentences are Fred likes Fred.
Fred likes Marnie.
Fred likes Wilma.
Fred thinks red.
Fred thinks Barney,
Fred thinks woman.
And so on the three nouns followed by
any of the two verbs followed by any of
the three nouns.
That is not a very interesting language,
but now take a more complicated language.
Same vocabulary,
the same three nouns,
the same two verbs,
the same sentence.
But now one other sentence.
This sentence expands to
a noun followed by a verb,
followed by a sentence.
And there you get recursion.
You have one rule invoking another rule,
and then you can get a
sentence like Fred thinks,
okay,
Barney likes woman,
okay.
And here you get a potential
infinity of sentences.
And this is obviously a toy example,
but you could see their use of recursion
in everyday life in everyday use of
language.
You could say John hates cheese.
My roommate heard a rumor
that John hates cheese.
It disturbed Mary when I
told her that my roommate,
her roommate at John hates cheese.
I was amazed at the disturbed
Mary when I told her that.
My roommate heard a rumor that John
hates cheese professor voluma devoted way
too much of his lecture.
Talking about how he was amazed at
Mister mayor when I told her that,
my roommate heard a rumor that John H,
Jeez,
it really bothered me that,
and,
and there's no limit.
There's no longest sentence.
You could keep producing a sentence
deeper and deeper in bed until you die.
Um,
and this is part of the power of language.
Now the syntactic rules are complicated
and one of the puzzles of syntactic
rules are,
one of the issues of them is that
different rules can conspire to create the
same sentence.
So you take a sentence like this is
a classic line from Groucho Marx.
I wanted to shot an
elephant in my pajamas,
Howard gone into my pajamas,
I'll never know.
And the humor such that it is,
revolves around the ambiguity of rules
that generate it like this versus like
this often to illustrate
issues of ambiguity,
people have collected poorly thought
out headlines in newspaper reports,
um,
that play on that,
that,
that inadvertently,
uh,
have ambiguity complaints of
an NBA referees growing ugly.
He says you really have that structure.
Kids make nutritious snacks.
No one was injured in a blast,
which was attributed to the bill
of gas by one town official.
Um,
last,
last summer I was in Seoul,
uh,
visiting the visiting Korea
University and the big headline,
their front page was general
arrested for fondling privates.
Um,
now there actually is,
there ambiguity is that is actually quite
difficult to avoid in the construction
and understanding of sentences.
It's one of the,
it's one of the ways in which is
often difficult to write clearly.
And in fact,
there's a whole subfield of the law
involving the use of linguistic theory to
disambiguate sentences both in,
um,
in the constitution,
in a,
in,
in legislation,
in legislation as well as
in some criminal cases.
And there was several years ago a very
serious criminal case that rested on a
sentence.
And here's what happened.
There were two brothers,
one of them retarded and they get into
a robbery and a police officer sees them
and points the gun at them.
And uh,
one of the brothers points
a gun at a police officer.
The police officer shouts for the brother,
the non retarded brother to
drop the gun as she said,
give me the gun.
The retarded brother shouted,
let him have it were upon to brother
shot and killed a police officer.
Now the brother had did the
shooting was plainly a murder.
What about that brother who
showed it to let them have it?
Well,
it depends on what on,
on how you interpret that sentence.
Because this sentence is
beautifully ambiguous.
It could mean shoot him,
let him have it or it could
mean give him the gun.
Let him have it.
And in fact the trial,
which I think somebody could,
if people have the know about this,
please send me an email.
My understanding was he was found guilty.
Um,
but a lot to turn on the
ambiguity of a sentence.
I want to shift now and talk about
where does all this knowledge come from,
but I'll stop and answer any
questions about material so far.
What are your questions?
Yes.
Syntax.
And the question is how is
syntax different from grammar?
They're exactly the same.
Uh,
syntax is a more technical term,
but typically,
but it means the same thing as grammar.
Yes.
Every normal like normal
human being is born.
Others,
that kind of language.
How about,
are there cases where people were
born when they had the culture?
Never really spoke life
into them physically?
Yes.
I'm glad.
I'm glad you actually asked me
about that because as I said it,
I realized it wasn't quite right.
The point that was just raised here is
I had said before to everybody who's
neurologically normal comes to
acquire and learn a language.
But what about people who
are neurologically normal
but they don't have language
around them?
And in fact,
there's been historically
some cases of this,
um,
there's been probably apocryphal stories
about children who are raised by wolves
or by dogs.
There are stories,
horrible stories summon that summon a
20th century about children who are locked
away by insane or evil parents
and who never learned to speak.
There are stories of deaf people who are
within certain societies where nobody
signs to them.
And so they're what's known as linguistic
isolates and they themselves never
learned to speak.
Um,
and those cases are
the dramatic exception.
And they do tell you something.
They tell you that it's not enough
to have a brain for language.
Somebody does have to use it with you.
Interestingly,
um,
it doesn't have to be that many people.
So as Susan Golden Meadow has studied
deaf children that nobody signed to,
but what she studies is deaf
children with deaf siblings.
And these children don't just sit there.
They create their own language.
It's not a full blown language like
American sign language are long,
the scene Quebecois.
But it's a language.
Nonetheless with words
and syntax and phonology.
It's an interesting question.
Um,
any other
questions?
Yes,
it's a good question.
The question is,
are there inherent limits in our
abilities to come up with grammars?
And most linguists would argue yes,
that languages are highly
constrained in how they do things.
So for instance,
one example is,
um,
there's no language in the world that
ever constructs a question by switching
the order of words around in a sentence.
Um,
there's no language in the world that has
a rule that says the fifth word has to
be a verb.
And linguists have all these conditions.
They no language in the
world works this way.
Now this is,
so these are on grammar and they're really
interesting cause they tell us what's
the human not humanly natural language
versus what's not a humanly natural
language.
But notice even after it was incredible
constraints on grammars still we could
still produce an infinite
number of sentences.
It's just like if you restrict
me to only a subset of numbers,
only the odd numbers,
um,
still there's an infinity of odd numbers.
So grammar can be restricted but still
give rise to an infinity of possible
sentences.
Well,
there's a radical claim
about the origin of language,
um,
associated with the guy who we met
when we talked about behaviorism,
who,
um,
who wrote the review of verbal behavior,
the linguist,
Noam Chomsky and Chomsky
makes us radical claim.
And this is that we shouldn't view
language learning as learning at all.
Instead we should view it as
something similar to growth.
So he says no one would
take seriously to proposal.
The human organism learns
through experience to have
arms rather than wings or
did the basic structure
particular Oregon's results
from accidental experience.
Language proves to be no less marvelous,
an intricate and east physical structures.
Why then should we not stay the
acquisition of a cognitive structure like
language,
more or less as we study
some complex bodily organ.
So you might learn to play baseball,
you might learn about
the American civil war,
but if Chomsky is right,
you didn't learn to speak English.
Rather,
what happened is you hurting leash and
and but the capacity grew in your head
and something a lot more similar to the
development of arms or legs or a visual
system.
Well,
should we believe this?
We know there has to be some effect
of the environment shaping language
obviously because in order to know
English you have to have heard English.
In order to know Dutch,
you have had to herd to add,
to have learned and heard Dutch.
And in fact languages differ in all
the ways that we were talking about.
Um,
some languages like English has it
have a distinction mean Ellen are other
languages do not.
Um,
for language like English,
that creature there is referred
to with the morphine dog.
That's a historical accident of English.
In French it's shit.
And then,
and in Greek it's something else.
And each of those 6,000 languages and
people in a room who know other languages,
they,
yeah.
In Vietnamese is this inner do,
what is this in check?
It's that.
Okay.
Finally there's syntax.
So English is what's
known as a subject verb,
object language.
That means if you want to convey
the idea that bill hit John,
you would say bill hit John.
But not all languages work that way.
In fact,
a majority of language is more languages,
uh,
are actually subject,
object,
verb languages.
So you would say if you wanted to convey
that bill was to hit her and John was
hit bill John hit.
All of this has to be learned and all of
this has to be learned through exposure
to language users.
On the other hand,
there is considerable evidence that the
development of these language skills,
um,
in some way is similar to growth
in a way that Chompsky suggests.
So here's some basic facts
about language development.
One is something which
I had mentioned before.
Um,
all normal children learn language.
There can be specific
impairments of language.
Now again,
we spoke about them before
when talking about the brain.
Some of these impairments
could be due to trauma.
Um,
the phase aphasias trauma,
a bloated ahead,
a stroke can read,
you have your language,
but also there are genetic disorders.
Um,
some falling under the rubric of what's
known as specific language impairment,
where children are born without the same
ability as the rest of us to learn to
speak.
And these are interesting in many ways.
One reason that they're interesting is
that he illustrates something about human
language.
It is not,
it would not be unreasonable for you to
think before listening to his lecture.
Look,
all you need to,
to have to learn a language is to be
smart or all you need to have to learn a
language is to want to communicate or
all you need to have to learn a language
is to be a social person wanting to,
having the ability to understand
others and deal with others.
But the cases,
specific language impairments suggest
that all of that is wrong because there
are children in this world right now
who are plenty smart who really want to
communicate and who are entirely social
creatures but they can't learn language.
And this suggests that the ability to
learn language and understand language is
to some extent separate from these
other aspects of mental life.
Um,
continuing on this theme,
we also know that language is learned
without any sort of feedback or training.
Um,
there are many Americans who believe
that they need to teach your children
language and there's a huge industry
with DVDs and flashcards and all sorts of
things,
um,
designed to teach your children language.
And I think many parents believe that
they didn't persist in using these things.
Their children would never learn to speak.
Um,
but we know that that's not true.
We know this isn't true
because there are communities,
um,
where they,
they don't speak to their kids.
They don't speak to your kids because
they don't believe it's important to speak
to their kids.
Um,
some linguists it would interview
linguist would interview adults in these
communities and say,
why don't you speak to your babies?
And these adults would respond.
It is ridiculous to speak to a baby.
The baby has nothing to say.
You might as well just speak to your dog.
And then the American linguist would say,
yeah,
we speak to our dogs.
Um,
Americans and Europeans speak
to everything and everybody,
um,
other cultures are more picky and they
don't talk to children until their
children and themselves are talking.
Um,
this doesn't seem to make much of
a difference in language learning.
Some studies have motivated
by Chomsky's work,
um,
in uh,
in,
in express,
sorry,
motivated by Chomsky's
critique of Skinner's verbal
behavior have asked even in
what if we just looked at
children within the United States?
Don't these,
these children get feedback?
And answer is yes and no.
So your average highly educated
Western parent does give their children
feedback,
do give their children feedback,
um,
based on what they say,
but they don't typically give feedback
based on the syntax or grammatical
quality of what they say.
Um,
the example given by Brown and handling
and the classic study in the 1970s,
is they did all these studies looking
at what children say and how parents
responded.
And it turns out parents respond
not to the grammatical correctness,
but to the effect or acuteness our
associate ability of the utterance.
So,
for instance,
um,
if a child says to his mother,
I loves you mummy,
it's a very unusual parent who say,
oh no,
the verb agreement is mistaken.
You've,
you've added a redundant s uh,
it is not appropriate.
Um,
similarly,
if a child has to say,
you know,
I hate your guts,
mother,
it's an unusual mother.
That's wonderful.
And subject,
verb,
object,
the whole thing structurally fine.
You know,
we respond to our kids like we respond
to each other based on a message that's
conveyed not to grammatic
Cali to utterances.
Children make grammatical
mistakes all the time,
but then they go away and they
go away without correction.
So those are some basic facts.
Um,
what do we know about the
time course of language?
Well,
early on,
children's start off and they prefer
the melody of their own language.
Um,
these studies were done in a,
in France,
um,
we're four day old babies and what they
did was they used a sucking method.
Remember,
there's a limited number
of things babies can do it.
One of the things they can do is suck
and these babies would suck on a pacifier
to hear French.
Um,
and they would prefer to hear
French than to hear Russian.
And these investigators claim this
is because they had been exposed to,
um,
to French in the first
four days of their lives.
Reviewers mostly from
France objected and said,
no,
maybe French sounds better.
Everybody kind of like French.
Somebody redid this study in Russia.
Russian kids sucked harder to hear
Russian than he did to French.
And what they're listening
to isn't the words,
they don't know words yet.
They don't know how to syntax yet.
It's the rhythm of the language.
Um,
for you.
French and Russian sound different.
Even if you're like me,
you don't know word of either language.
They still sound different.
They sound different to babies too.
And a baby being raised in France or a
baby being raised in Russia knows enough
to um,
to tell what's his
language and what isn't.
Um,
early on,
children are sensitive to
every phoneme there is.
Um,
so English speaking children for instance,
can English speaking babies,
babies who are born in the United
States can distinguish between English
phonemes like lip and rip,
but it can also distinguish
between phonemic contrasts,
um,
that are not exemplified in English
such as phonemic contrasts and check or
Hindi.
Yes.
Gaggle and Kubek had a baby.
No,
I mean it doesn't matter what you say.
There's,
there's a lot going on in your question.
There's a lot going on.
Your question.
Um,
the question,
the question was,
um,
your baby's going to
crew and gag at Google.
Doesn't matter if you coop and gag.
I go back.
No,
it doesn't make a difference.
Your hatred towards them was,
was unmotivated.
Um,
you can be relieved of that debt.
And I know you feel bad now I guess.
Um,
if you,
if you speak to your
children and perfect English,
it's very strange.
You know,
nobody speaks to their
babies and you know,
no.
Hello.
Because I understand going.
Okay.
What changed your diaper
right now since he's still,
that's bad parenting sounds kind of silly.
More than what most people do.
Oh,
you're such a cute little baby.
Um,
and it probably one,
there's,
there's evolutionary psychologists debate
the function of why we talk funny to
babies and some people have argued
it does help their language learning.
Um,
and some people have argued instead
that what it does is it calms them.
They like to hear the music of,
of a smooth voice and so on.
But whether or not you do so it
doesn't need to make a big difference.
It is very difficult to find any effects
of how parents talk to their kids on
how their kids learn language,
particularly when it comes to babies.
So early on,
babies can are sensitive to old phonemes.
Um,
and then that goes away,
uh,
around 12 months of age.
It goes away.
This is one thing.
You were much better that when
you were a baby then you are now,
when you were a baby,
you were a multilingual for,
you could understand the sound
differences of every language on earth.
Now if you're like me,
you could barely understand English.
You've,
you,
you narrow down to your sensitive
just to the language you hear.
And this narrowing down is largely
in place by about 12 months of age.
Around seven months is babbling
and I want to stop at this point.
To go back to the issue I promised you,
I would turn a bit to sign language and
I want to describe now a very elegant,
I want to show a little film now,
have a very elegant series of experiments
looking at the question of whether
babies who are exposed with sign language
babble.
One of the real surprising findings in
my field over the last 10 20 years has
been that the acquisition of sign
languages as turned out to be,
yeah,
almost exactly the same.
In fact,
as far as we know exactly the same
as acquisition of spoken languages,
it didn't have to be that way.
I mean,
it could have been just as reasonable to
expect that there'd be an advantage for
speech over sign that sign languages
may be full blown languages,
but you know,
they just take heart.
They're just harder to learn because
the brain and the body have adapted for
speech.
It turns out that this
just isn't the case.
It turns out that sign and at
the developmental milestones
of sign languages and
the development milestones or spoken
languages are precisely the same.
They start babbling at the same point.
They start using first words,
first sentences,
first complicated constructions.
Um,
there seems to be no interesting
difference between how the brain comes to
acquire and use spoken language
versus a sign language.
Around 12 months of age,
children,
um,
started using their first words.
These are words for,
um,
objects and actions like
dog and op and milk.
Um,
they start showing some sensitivity to
the order of words so they know that,
you know,
dog bites cat is different from cat bites.
Dog Ran 18 months of age.
They start learning words faster.
They start producing
little miniature sentences,
um,
like,
you know,
want cookie or milk spill.
Um,
and a function morphine's a
little words in of the and so on.
Start to gradually up here.
Okay.
Then the,
then there's the bad news.
Um,
around seven years of age,
I'm going up through puberty.
The ability to learn
language starts to go away.
Um,
the best work on this has been done
by Alyssa Newport and Samsung Holla,
um,
who have studied people who have
been in the United States for many,
many years,
like 30,
40 years and seeing how well
they have come to speak English.
And it turns out the big determinant
of how well you speak English as an
immigrant isn't how smart you are.
It's not how many family members
you have when you're here.
It's not your motivation is how
old you were when you started.
It turns out that if you
start learning a language,
a second language is where most of the
work's been done within the first few
years of life.
You're fine,
you'll speak like a native,
but then it starts
getting worse and worse.
And once you hit puberty,
suddenly there's huge variation in the
abilities you have to learn language.
It is very rare.
For instance,
for somebody who has learned English
passed puberty to speak without an accent,
an accent is very hard to shake and it's
not just an accent is also funnel is
also other aspects of phonology,
syntax and morphology.
It's like the part of the brain that's
responsible for language learning is only
around early in development.
Um,
and if you don't get
your language by then,
um,
it'll just run out.
I want us to begin next
class with this question.
Yeah.
The question of animals and that will
shut down the language learning part.
But one thing
put up here
is your second reading response.
I'll also put this up on Wednesday and
by Wednesday you might have a bit of a
better cause it be in a better
position to answer this question,
but I'll continue with language on
Wednesday and then we'll also talk about
vision,
attention and memory.
I'll see you then.